[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis guten abend und
herzlich willkommen welche medaillen das
deutsche team heute bei den paralympics
gewonnen hat erfahren sie von norbert
lehmann ganz schön schauen wir auf die
großen themen dieser sendung
afghanistan nach den anschlägen die usa
üben vergeltung immer mehr menschen
versuchen das land zu verlassen
hamburgs corona sonderweg gaststätten
clubs und kinos können selbst
entscheiden ob sie nur noch für geimpfte
und genießen eröffnen
trauer aber auch die mahnung mehr gegen
den klimawandel zu tun beim gedenken im
aachener dom an die opfer der flut
auch die usa haben jetzt mit ihrem abzug
vom flughafen kabul begonnen bis
dienstag wollen sie afghanistan
verlassen nachdem bei dem schweren
selbstmordanschlag am donnerstag am
flughafen auf us-soldaten getötet wurden
haben die usa nun als reaktion mit einem
drohnenangriff zwei hochrangige es
mitglieder getötet und ein weiteres
mitglied verletzt so die angaben des
pentagons jörg brase über die lage in
afghanistan
die wut treibt sie auf die straßen der
hauptstadt kabul
sie sind wütend wegen der chaotischen
lage im land und weil die banken
geschlossen sind und sie nicht an ihr
erspartes kommen
wir haben hart dafür gearbeitet es muss
irgendwie einen weg geben damit wären
unser geld kommen sonst werden viele
denken dass alles verloren ist und wir
werden die hoffnung in jede neue
regierung verlieren
die einen bangen um ihr geld die anderen
um das leben ihrer angehörigen wie
muster ba ihr vater wurde bei dem
selbstmordattentat vom donnerstag schwer
verletzt
es gibt tausende menschen die wie ich
vor den toren der krankenhäuser um den
flughafen herum auf nachricht warten
leute deren leben zerstört wurde und die
alles verloren
auch heute strömen wieder viele zum
flughafen obwohl die gefahr weiterer
terroranschläge gewachsen ist denn
vergangenen nacht übten die usa
vergeltung flogen einen drohnenangriff
gegen mitglieder des
zwei hochrangige zielpersonen des
islamischen staates wurden getötet einer
wurde verletzt wir wissen dass es keine
zivilen opfer gegeben wird
die taliban kündigten an den vorfall
untersuchen zu wollen denn angeblich
habe es doch zivile opfer gegeben
während die taliban versuchen eine
regierung zu bilden verlassen die
letzten ausländischen truppen das land
nach den deutschen beendeten heute auch
briten franzosen und italiener ihre
evakuierungsflüge nun versuchen die
verzweifelten auf dem landweg
rauszukommen bilder von der
pakistanischen grenze morgen reist
außenminister maß in die nachbarstaaten
afghanistans wohl auch um über die
aufnahme von flüchtlingen zu reden
claudia betzin washington drohnenangriff
auf hochrangige ex kämpfer ist das jetzt
die neue strategie des us-präsidenten um
zu verhindern dass sich die terror miliz
in afghanistan weiter ausbreitet
zunächst ist es mal ein teil der erste
teil der vergeltung die us-präsident
beiden jahr unmittelbar angekündigt
hatte das pentagon sagt nichts dazu ob
die beiden jetzt getöteten terroristen
in den anschlag am flughafen direkt
verwickelt waren aber es gibt wohl
hinweise darauf dass einer von beiden
weitere anschläge geplant haben soll und
die us-militärs rechnen mit weiteren
anschlägen am flughafen in kabul die
lage sei gefährlicher denn je
gleichzeitig ist klar dass es mit diesem
einen drohnenangriff nicht getan ist
denn die gefährdungslage in afghanistan
für die usa ist ja vielschichtig da gibt
es die islamistischen taliban da gibt es
den afghanischen arm des da gibt's
al-kaida die sich dort wieder formieren
könnten daher gehen
militär analysten davon aus dass die usa
sich wieder nach dem truppenabzug in
einer art krieg gegen den terrorismus
aus afghanistan begeben müssen und dass
der auch eine breitere militärische
strategie erfordert und nicht allein mit
nadelstichen aus der ferne wie diesen
drohnenangriff geführt werden kann
vielen dank für diese einschätzung
claudia bates
die bundeswehr ist ja bereits aus
afghanistan abgezogen fast alle soldaten
und soldatinnen sind jetzt wieder zurück
in deutschland
heute ist noch ein sanitäts flugzeug auf
dem niedersächsischen
luftwaffenstützpunkt wunstorf gelandet
nachdem gestern dort bereits ein
großteil der einsatzkräfte eingetroffen
ist empfang unter anderem von der
verteidigungsministerin heike slansky
mit den einzelheiten
gestern abend der general und seine
chefin ein bild das bände spricht
erleichterung und dankbarkeit für die
gesunde rückkehr der soldaten von einem
einsatz der ihn noch in den knochen
steckt eine hochdynamische einsatz mit
nichts zu vergleichen was sie bis dato
erlebt habe
wo jeder an seine belastungsgrenze geht
und jeder sich einbringt um das ganze
möglich zu machen
ankunft im fliegerhorst wunstorf bei
hannover nach elf gefährlichen tagen in
kabul unter anderem
fallschirmjäger sanitäter angehörige der
luftwaffe auf sicherem boden nach dem
größten evakuierungseinsatz der
geschichte der bundeswehr die
verteidigungsministerin dankte zollte
respekt mehr als 5000 menschen wurden
ausgeflogen zu viele jedoch blieben
zurück ich denke heute abend auch an
diejenigen die in kabul zurück geblieben
sind und von der wir gesagt haben in
einer zweiten phase wir werden alles
daran setzen sie in den nächsten tagen
wochen und monaten aus kabul aus
afghanistan heraus zu holen eine mission
die längst nicht abgeschlossen ist und
politisch ein nachspiel haben wird der
heutige tag
ist angesichts der dramatischen lage in
afghanistan kein grund zum feiern aber
es ist ein tag zur würdigung der
erfolgreichen evakuierung vor zwei
stunden kehrte auch der sanitäts
flugzeug der bundeswehr aus dem
usbekischen taschkent zurück bei diesem
einsatz waren keine verletzten zu
beklagen
zur corona pandemie in deutschland sind
inzwischen mehr als 60 prozent der
menschen vollständig geimpft tendenz
langsam weiter steigend es könnte
schneller gehen findet zumindest hamburg
und erhöht jetzt den druck auf die
ungeimpften mit dem zweig optionsmodell
entscheiden sich kinos restaurants und
clubs in der stadt dafür heißt das sie
dürfen nur noch geimpfte und genesen
reinlassen dafür fallen bei ihnen fast
alle corona beschränkungen weg alle
tische und stühle könnten wieder genutzt
werden martin neeson hat sich das
angeschaut
mit countdown und konfetti in die neue
zeit in der wunderbar auf sein pauli
wurde punkt mitternacht auf das 2g
modell umgestellt zutritt haben nur noch
geimpfte und genießen
die vorteile liegen auf der hand für
teilnehmende betriebe entfallen die
abstands licht beschränkungen bei der
gästezahl und auch die sperrstunde ab 23
uhr wir haben tatsächlich betrieben die
seit 18 monaten geschlossen sind weil
sie keinen großen außenbereich haben und
durch die abstandsregeln einfach keine
auslastung kommen würden mit denen sich
wirtschaftlich arbeiten lässt und gerade
für die macht es sinn auch der besitzer
der bar lohnt red meldet sich im
behörden portal für das 2g modell an er
brauche etwas mehr vorbereitungszeit
aber ab montag wolle er mitmachen das
ist für mich gut dass es für den staat
gut weil dann kann ich endlich wieder
steuern zahlen und kann dann auch wieder
meine leute aus der kurzarbeit holen bin
nicht mehr selber auf hartz iv
angewiesen in diesem fitnessstudio
bleiben sie bei 3g lassen also neben
geimpften nun genesenen auch getestete
trainieren und wirtschaftlich macht das
aktuell keinen sinn von uns jetzt leute
auszuschliessen wir sind schon gebeutelt
genug und jetzt würde leute ausschließen
ich komme mit der variante klar wo wir
aktuell sind außerdem hält er zweig für
eine art indirekte impfpflicht so oder
so hamburgs vorpreschen befeuert die
diskussion um die aufhebung von
einschränkungen für menschen die geimpft
oder chinesen sind blicken wir auf die
aktuellen corona zahlen für deutschland
das robert koch institut meldet 10.300
drei neue infektionen innerhalb von 24
stunden das sind 2211 mehr als vor einer
woche
22 menschen starben im zusammenhang mit
kobe 19 binnen eines tages die sieben
tage incidents liegt nun bei
72,1
das hochwasser im rheinland pfalz und
nordrhein westfalen kommt wohl viele vor
ort überraschend mit verheerenden folgen
mehr als 180 menschen starben die
erinnerung an diese tage mitte juli
bleiben heute nun wurde mit einem
ökumenischen gottesdienst an die toten
erinnert an das leid und die
zerstörungen im aachener dom waren
hinterbliebene betroffene und die
spitzen des staates dort ferber über die
zeremonie
die kerze war die einzige lichtquelle in
der flut sein pfarrhaus in schleiden
stand unter wasser
erinnerungen an einem morgen an dem alle
in trauer vereint sind betroffene helfer
politik vertreter der kirchen sie
gedenken derer die nun fehlen und sie
versuchen zu verarbeiten was sie erlebt
haben
die verluste werden von tag zu tag
deutlicher
neu hinzugekommen sind ängste die angst
so vieler betroffener
die angst vor dem vergessenwerden
wie geht s weiter fragen sie auch heute
der menschengemachte klimawandel sei bei
uns angekommen stellt der
ratsvorsitzende evangelischen kirche in
deutschland fest vielleicht werden wir
in 20 jahren auf diese tage
zurückschauen und sagen
die thematik dessen was damals passiert
ist die abgründe an leid
haben unser land zum nachdenken gebracht
es ist eine hoffnung hoffnung macht auch
die große hilfsbereitschaft in der
katastrophe solidarität wird es weiter
geben sagt der bundespräsident
wir wissen dass sie uns brauchen als
bundespräsident möchte ich ihnen
versichern
sie sind nicht allein die
höheren sie
vergessen sie nicht
trost denn der gemeinsamkeit in aachen
ist er zu spüren
für seine verdienste um die einheit
deutschlands und europas hat
alt-ministerpräsident bernhard vogel
heute den point alpha preis verliehen
bekommen vogel sei immer davon überzeugt
gewesen dass die deutsche teilung und
natürlich ist vogel ist der einzige
ministerpräsident der sowohl ein
bundesland in west als auch in
ostdeutschland regiert hat der point
alpha preis wird seit 2005 in der
gleichnamigen gedenkstätte an der
hessisch-thüringischen grenze verliehen
und alpha ist der name eines ehemaligen
us militärcamp dort
am 26 september am gleichen tag wie die
bundestagswahl also stimmen die berliner
innen auch über ein neues
abgeordnetenhaus ab die großen themen im
wahlkampf bezahlbarer wohnraum und der
verkehr dabei geht es um die staus aber
auch um fahrradwege und e-mobilität
sylvia bleßmann mit einem stimmungsbild
vor der wahrheit
berlin wächst tausende neuberliner
prägen jährlich das tempo der
dynamischen stadt die sich viel
schneller verändert als andere deutsche
städte was bewegt die bürger vor der
wahl es wird wahrscheinlich die
mietfrage sein weil es am meisten
menschen berührt weil der platz ja
relativ gering ist inzwischen also
bezahlbare mieten
kreuzberg und möglich natürlich mieten
wohnungen die mit deckel wäre ein
interessantes thema für uns
also ich finde die miete ziemlich hoch
verdoppelt haben sich die mieten in zehn
jahren viele haben angst vor verdrängung
es fehlen 100.000 wohnungen knapp die
hälfte aller berliner ist für die
enteignung großer wohn konzerne das
thema spaltet die stadt wenn du
eigentlich gesagt gar kein thema das
unterstütze ich komplett gar nicht weil
ich da sehr starken uns natürlich in die
demokratie wäre der mieten deckel
scheiterte die wohn misere bleibt
politik experten sehen zwei wichtige
themen die die berliner parteien im
wahlkampf antreiben definitiv das thema
mieten und wohnen und andere themen die
in der stadtplanung wichtig sind also
insbesondere infrastrukturen verkehr das
sind themen die die bürgerinnen und
bürger im alltag erleben wo die stadt
sich sehr verändert hat und auch der
leidensdruck dementsprechend sehr hoch
ist der immer dichter werdenden verkehr
zeigt berlin hat keinen masterplan für
eine verkehrswende auch bei diesem thema
unterschiedlicher haltungen vielmehr von
radverkehr auf jeden fall also wir haben
immer noch ein auto planung wir haben
eine 1a auto planung es gibt viele
fahrradfahrer in berlin aber nun alles
für die fahrradfahrer in berlin zu
machen sehe ich auch nicht ein mehr
elektromobilität weniger autos in der
innenstadt die verkehrswende ob sie an
reutte und wie schnell werden die wähler
entscheiden
protest gegen eine gewaltige
umweltkatastrophe im südosten von
spanien eine menschenkette mit etwa
70.000 demonstrierenden rund um das
sogenannte marino europas größte
salzwasser laguna hintergrund ist ein
dramatisches fischsterben es gelangen
zum beispiel viel zu viele düngemittel
aus der landwirtschaft ins wasser in der
vergangenen woche wurden fünf tonnen
toter fische aus dem meer geholt
und jetzt kommen wir zu den paralympics
da gab es ja heute einen regelrechten
medaillenregen für das deutsche team
aber bislang erfolgreichste wettkampftag
zweimal silber dreimal bronze fangen wir
mit dem weitsprung weltmeister liga und
schäfer hat gold nur ganz knapp verpasst
fünf zentimeter trennten ihn vom
überraschungssiegern tandem arango aus
südafrika
in seinem letzten versuch muslime und
schäfer für das fest eingeplante gold
mindestens sieben meter 17 springen doch
schließlich fehlen ihm zum sieg 5
hauchdünne zentimeter ich hab selber ich
bin auch der anteil teppich aber
natürlich der ärger überwiegt auf in
folge mit einer allerdings
halsbrecherischen sprung technik geht
gold überraschend an den südafrikaner
mal lange und leer und schäfer wird
sicher noch ein wenig zeit brauchen um
mit silber wirklich glücklich zu sein
ja und ganz eng ging es heute auch bei
der zweiten deutschen silbermedaille zu
die gab es im tischtennis für thomas mit
berger wie schon 2016 in rio hieß sein
finalgegner anfang aus china und wie
schon in rio unterlag diesmal knapp mit
2 3 sätzen es war ein drama um gold
diese niederlage schmerzt es gibt gold
und silber und ich hab selber und er hat
gold ich habe die ersten zwei sätze
verschlafen doch thomas schmidberger
kämpft und schafft es diesen 0 2
rückstand auszugleichen im fünften satz
beim stand von 4 4 geht er in führung
nach einem nervenaufreibenden
ballwechsel mit 55 schlägen zeigt er
gold ist drin doch dann dieser fehler
und plötzlich hat fängt zwei matchbälle
den ersten kann schmidberger noch
abwehren doch den zweiten verwandelt der
chinese feiert seinen vierten
paralympics sieg nacheinander
und auch die tischtennis frauen waren
erfolgreich stephanie kriebel holte eine
der drei deutschen bronzemedaillen des
heutigen tages
die 33 jährige aus berlin verliert zwar
ihr halbfinale gegen die europameisterin
maria kaliner aus russland da der dritte
platz aber nicht ausgespielt wird hat
sie bronze sicher ihre zweite
paralympische medaille nach silber in
rio 2016
für verena schott ist es die zweite
bronzemedaille bei diesen paralympics
über ihre paradestrecke 100 meter brust
schlägt sie auf bahn 2 nur 12
hundertstel sekunden vor der
viertplatzierten an
unerwartet der dritte platz von
sprinterin in die arme nach zwei jahren
verletzungspause gewinnt sie bronze über
100 meter mit persönlicher bestzeit
12,77 sekunden
und zur fußball bundesliga bayer
leverkusen hat die tabellenführung
übernommen nach dem sieg in augsburg
hier die bisherigen ergebnisse des
dritten spieltags
augsburg leverkusen eins zu vier
stuttgart verliert gegen freiburg 23
mainz schlägt aufsteiger führt mit 13 0
köln bochum 2 1 bielefeld und frankfurt
1 1 das abends spiel bayern münchen
gegen hertha bsc bereits gestern
besiegte dortmund ii tsg hoffenheim mit
3 zu 2 morgen dann noch union berlin
gegen gladbach in wolfsburg in leipzig
ja die tabelle leverkusen vor den
punktgleichen freiburgern dortmund
dritter dahinter köln mainz wolfsburg
und hoffenheim die zweite hälfte beginnt
mit bochum und am tabellenende greuther
fürth vor augsburg und hertha und das
abendspiel bayern gegen hertha bsc
ausführlich bei uns im aktuellen
sportstudio 23
es geht aufwärts jetzt also mit den
temperaturen um ganz langsam nächste
woche für morgen hat katja horne
vergleich aber ersten durchwachsene
aussichten das heute-journal können sie
um 22 45 sehen mit claus kleber schön an
[Musik]
guten abend es ist noch spätsommer fühlt
sich aber an wie herbst und das liegt
eine kombination von technik und hochbau
ja denn so kommt der wind aus nördlichen
aus nordöstlichen richtungen und dieser
wind kommt nicht so ganz alleine daher
sondern er bringt regengebiete mit und
die sind zum teil auch mit gewittern
durchsetzt und erreichen auch morgen
wieder die alb ganz ähnlich war das ja
schon heute ist gab kräftige schauer und
gewitter vor allen dingen auch am
nordrand der mittelgebirge und der alpen
hielten die sich mal länger ähnlich
sieht es auch in der nacht aus und wenn
es mal kurz klar ist dann bildet sich
gleich nebel oder dunst denn es wird
kühl im südosten sinken die temperaturen
auf null bis sechs grad sonst geht's auf
16 bis 11 grad runter und morgen bleibt
es richtig kalt am alpenrand da werden
das nur 12 grad sonst immerhin 15 bis 17
und am rhein 19 grad sich der nördlichen
mittelgebirge aber steigen die werte auf
18 bis 21 grad und am wärmsten wird in
schleswig holstein denn dort steigen die
chancen auf sonne am höchsten sonst aber
wird das ein trüber sonntag immer wieder
mit regen und mit gewittern und erst in
der kommenden woche bis mittwoch
steigern sich die sonnen anteile und die
temperaturen guten abend